down here so that we can chat with Irish
Chang Irish trick hi I'm Connie Dudley
nice to meet you welcome to poke TV um
thank you for holding on your new book
first of all we just finished a panel on
culture and the culture of fear what's
your thoughts when you think about your
topic which you usually talked about the
Chinese in America and also your
historical book they The Rape of Nanking
as it is it looks at our culture today
and for some people believing that there
is a culture of fear out there well
there definitely is a culture of fear
and I say that after 9/11 I mean some of
the treatment of ethnic minorities in
this country as such as Muslim Muslim
Americans have mirrored really the
persecution that Chinese Americans
experienced during the exclusion error
so I think we have to constantly be
aware of some of these cycles of history
and the Chinese America describes how at
various times the culture of fear or
like these exaggerated fears of China
and the American imagination led to
severe backlashes against the Chinese
American immigrant population
let me show both of your books iris
Chang's newest book which is out in
paperback is the Chinese in America
which is what 150 year epic saga of the
Chinese immigrant experiences country
and the fate of their descendants and
for book notes you appeared for this
book The Rape of Nanking that's right
and some people who may not be familiar
with Nanking what happened The Rape of
Nanking is the story of one of the
greatest atrocities world history when
the Japanese Imperial Army killed an
estimated 300,000 Chinese civilians and
also committed the single greatest mass
rape of world history at that time in
the capital of China in 1937 which was
the city of Nanking
our phone lines continue to be open we'd
invite you to join us 202 585 3 8 9 0 if
you live in the East or Central time
zone 202 5 8 5 3 8 9 1 if you live in
the mountain or Pacific time zone let's
go to your vanora book the Chinese in
America first of all why do you feel you
need to tell this story well I just felt
that there was a lack of really good and
accurate information on the Chinese
American immigrant experience and that
excellent books on the topic but they
came out decades ago and I I really
wanted to expose not just some of the
stories of prejudice of this story the
great contributions of Chinese Americans
to the United States this should not be
seen as like a foreign or ethnic story
but rather as the quintessential
American story it's a history of the
United States itself as seen through the
perspective of one of its immigrant
groups and I found that every generation
had to struggle for their civil
liberties and democracy in this country
and it's an ongoing struggle so there
are a lot of cautionary stories in here
that was Texas you're first up with iris
Chang hello hello I wanted to say thanks
c-span if you lift up your camera and
look around at all the people around you
we are fighting the fear the fact that
you're standing there talking to that
woman who is telling us we don't have to
be afraid people that write the books
that tell us without c-span you don't
see this and it is what America needs to
see that these people are not afraid
we're not afraid we are learning how to
assimilate all the information but there
are plenty of channels and c-span's one
of them and we thank you thank you thank
you well I agree that there are many
ways we could get this information out
but still there's so much information
about not about American history or the
Chinese American American experience
that really isn't what commonly known
and that's why I wrote the back up of an
example I didn't know that
one in five Chinese Americans in this
country during World War two served in
the US Armed Forces I mean there's
probably no other ethnic group they gave
so much I mean in percentage-wise other
population to the US military yet we
have seen retrospectives on World War
two and we look at an Asian man in a
uniform we usually think of him as a
Japanese enemy soldier or as you know
maybe a chinese nationalist soldier you
know trying a foreigner and and there
are other there's so many other
contributions well I mean not just the
fact that for example you know that we
have had so many Chinese and saw the
sciences and Technology the Nobel
laureates but just how they laid down
the foundation of civil rights law in
this country was a really intriguing
development as I research this book for
example the u.s. right to birthright
citizenship was reinforced and protected
by a Chinese American lawsuit Wong Kim
Ark versus u.s. which now means that
every American who is born on earth
every person who's born on American soil
is a US citizen whether or not they're
their parents or their grandparents were
citizens or eligible for for citizenship
so and it's it's really kind of
incredible it's what distinguishes our
country from others which such as
Germany or Japan where you know you the
your citizenship depends on the
citizenship of your ancestors and you've
got permanent for an under classes such
as Koreans who are living in Japan for
generations but they're not really
considered Japanese citizens so but you
know I'm glad you brought up the
rationale the culture of fear because we
now that our birthright citizenship
rights have been challenged thanks to
new legislation after
we have you know we have challenges to
that where that could be stripped from
us if we are deemed a subversive or
supportive of terrorist groups so I
think we have to recognize that every
generation of Americans will have to
fight to uphold our system a democracy
is ongoing struggle and that's that's
pretty much part of our responsibility
as Americans next call Hawaii hello yes
this is Hilo Hawaii hello yes the Mohan
from Hawaii one of the comments I wanted
to make to miss Chang is that one of the
things that is really unfortunate is
that labels are given to people without
without proper reason to do so in other
words everybody is a citizen the United
States if you're born in the United
States whether you're criminal or a
thief or whether you're in prison or
whatever mouths actions you may be
guilty of doing and in order to be a
citizen it really requires you to act
like the citizens of the United States
of America in your proportion to be able
to do so there's really too much
emphasis put on what a person ancestors
were this was brought up in the last
panel discussions in which Shermer
talked about people act like being
tribal beings one has to really extend
one concept of what one's neighbor is in
loving thy neighbor and there is at
least one culprit as basis
I agree we have to look beyond ethnicity
to see some of the underlying human
rights issues we talk about upholding
our American democratic system if we're
not careful we could end up a bit
fractured and vulcanized as a nation and
it's a it's it's going to be interesting
in the next few decades because by the
year 2050 there will be no more dominant
racial majority in this country so we
could either evolve towards being a
nation that looks past color and race
and ethnicity and really and focus on
character and contribution or we if
we're not careful we could establish an
elaborate racial hierarchy like what
we've seen in countries like South
Africa and and it really is going to
depend on on the choices we Americans
make when you go before Chinese American
groups are you able to look them in the
eye and say you know the idea of
identity politics and the idea of
identity assimilation does not work for
them well actually whenever I'm speaking
before Chinese American groups I always
emphasize especially if I hear questions
like well sometimes I feel like I'm half
American half Chinese I always emphasize
no you are 100% American you can embrace
your cultural heritage like so many
other ethnic groups have done but you
are still a US citizen if you were born
here and you have entitled to all the
rights and privileges and also of course
you have to undertake all the
obligations that comes with being a US
citizen we must never forget that and I
always remind them the IRS always they
certainly think of them as citizens so
it's important to have to exert alright
so I am always emphasizing this and that
that you know that the issue of cultural
identity of being very proud of your
heritage and also are are right and
privileges as a US citizen that those
are two very separate issues
and you know and we have to we have to
do our best really to to educate people
about that our system we have to be
involved in grassroots activism if it's
the bet of the number of people the
critical minority dips below certain
level our republic will not have a
chance to survive so I'm always I've
always emphasizing the importance of
sustaining our American democratic
experiment it is very much a young and
fragile experiment take one more call
for you
caller where are you calling from at
Santa Barbara Santa Barbara in the air
go ahead Santa Barbara hmm yeah miss
Chang um I thanks for making that
distinction between race identity and
citizenship my question to you is is to
your citizenship part if you you know
with all the problems that are facing
Americans as far as government
governance being clogs with corporate
money so to speak would you be
interested as a citizen would you be
open to the idea of a constitutional
convention a constitutional convention
you do Mike color well basically a
constitutional convention is like a
national forum it's just to propose
ideas to the 50 states and whatever
ideas are proposed at the convention if
38 states or more agree yes this is a
good idea to be from the Constitution
than it is so my question is would you
be in favor of a national convention
just to propose ideas and didn't get a
chance to see what everyone thinks I'm
certainly interested in having national
dialogues and
having national forums absolutely you
know one one thing that has constantly
come out in in my research as I've
written the threat of the silk room The
Rape of Nanking and the Chinese in
America is really the theme of power and
the dangers of power and and you know
having these kinds of forms are going to
make our society safer because the
empirical research has shown that the
more concentrated the power in the hands
of a government or any kind of ruling
class elite regardless of you know the
more country that power regardless of
that groups race religion or culture or
any other factor that group is more
likely to commit to human rights
atrocities both at home and abroad
initiate war with their neighbors and so
democracy true democracy you know has to
be championed a diffusion of power has
to be has to be promoted in order to
make our society safer that's what the
research on genocide is shown and and
education is one such force to defuse
power it returns power to the people and
engaging our leaders in dialogue in
making or demand access to government
records of a really kind of promoting a
marketplace of ideas all of that is
imperative to the survival of democracy
so I would absolutely be favor of having
national dialogues on the subject what
are you doing now I'm actually you know
I'm I'm continuing to do a lot of
research I've been touring right now the
country to promote the Chinese America
but I'd like to get started on my fourth
book you know i I've spearheaded an oral
history project
world war two world history project
which is gained institutional support
and there's like certain stories that
are emerging from that that might be
great topics for a fourth book so and so
I would really urge people who are
interested in my research or maybe even
sharing some of their stories with me to
go to my website which is iris Chang net
Sun net yeah thank you very much it's
nice to see you it's that pleasure okay
take care we are continuing our live
coverage